The opening of the helm steep battle
scene in the two towers reminds me a lot
of the opening scene from Sergio Leone
once upon a time in the west.
Both movies have classic scores,
but both use silence and some spare
foley sound effects.
To set the stage,
silence is important because a battle
like a shootout is all about contract.
Helm's deep is full of contrasts as a 39
minute sequence.
It has to carry the dramatic weight,
the ups and downs of a mini movie within
a movie to hold our attention.
In fact,
since the two towers is essentially the
middle of a larger story,
Peter Jackson and his co writer writers
needed the battle to be climactic enough
to provide enough temporary closure that
the film could stand on its own.
In the end,
it's that necessity which I think
generated the best cinematic battle of
the trilogy and one of the best movie
battles of all time.
You can break the home Steve Battle or
the battle of the Hornberger,
as it's known in the books into 24
beats.
These beats provide a rough layout for
the rhythm of the sequence.
By the way,
speaking of contrast,
you can see looking at it this way,
that a large part of the battle is
virtually monochromatic.
The late great cinematographer Andrew
Lesson,
he had a really difficult task of
maintaining the feel of a night battle
and the rain while making sure that the
visuals were intelligible enough to the
viewer.
He does this by infusing the scene with
a strong bluish backlight extensively
the moon,
which draws out edges and by keeping the
color palate very limited,
he ensures that shots aren't too busy
for the eyes and brains of the audience.
Intelligibility is really important for
a giant set piece like this.
Not only do you want the audience to be
able to see what's happening,
you want them to have a sense of how the
fighting is developing for each side,
which is why these 24 narrative beats
are crucial.
Each beat represents an action or
development that carries an emotional
cue,
whether it's the feeling of anticipation
at the start or the feeling of
vulnerability.
When the euro explode,
the deepening wall and March up the
causeway or the feeling of hope at
sunrise,
and when Gandalf finally arrives,
if you were to graph the progress of the
battle using these 24 beats along an
axis of how close the heroes were to
victory or defeat,
it would look something like this.
What strikes me right away is that this
shape resembles almost exactly a
traditional story arc in miniature
complete with inciting
incident,
growing obstacles,
mini triumphs,
and a roaring Victoria's climax just
when things are at their most.
Steve really is a movie within a movie.
It has a fully realized narrative
structure that that parallels the
narrative shape of the trilogy where
things get darker and darker and closer
to defeat with some small victories
along the way,
including home steep itself,
but only at the very end when all hope
is lost.
Does the climactic triumph occur?
Having a complete narrative arc like
this is how you keep an audience
interested in a 39 minute sequence,
but to keep them invested,
you have to do even more.
As I said before,
home steep is full of contrasts of close
hand,
hand fighting contrast with sweeping
crane shots,
moments of levity,
elvish contrast with moments of tragedy,
darkness contrasts with light,
but with violent,
this reckless hate with moral
conviction.
One of the contrasts that Lord of the
rings always has to balance is the one
between the real and the mythic.
The film has to be emotionally realistic
enough to register on a personal level,
but it also has to have that extra
heightened element of fantasy,
of myth as if we're watching something
more perfect than a true story can be.
You see that in color Palette like I
mentioned,
but also in the rain and smoking other
atmospherics,
the peppered use of slow motion.
Of course there are shots like this.
It's these things that make the scenes
narrative arc three dimensional,
Peter Jackson,
Andrew,
less neat and the crews and actors who
spent four months of night shoots
filming the sequence,
not only made it easily comprehensible
for audiences,
but also resonate with the rest of the
film on the theme of darkness contrasted
with light that defines the trilogy.
Helm's deep is at once self contained
and a critical part of something bigger.
In other words,
it's not only a masterful sequence helps
the is the reason why epic battles.
There is a new nerd writer video every
Wednesday,
so if you click that new end screen
thing that I just figured out right over
there,
you'll subscribe to this channel
parently.
You can do it on your phone now,
which is Kinda cool.
So thank you for that and thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video.
If you don't know,
squarespace makes beautiful award
winning designer templates for your
website.
If you're an artist or a restaurant tour
or just a business person wants to make
a website,
squarespace is the perfect all in one
tool.
To do that,
it's flexible.
You have 24 slash seven customer
service,
easy domain names.
You don't have to know coding.
Just a really easy way to make a good
looking website.
If you use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So that's cool.
Thanks guys so much for that.
And Oh everybody who was at nerd condor
fighting area.
It was so awesome to meet you.
It was actually a conversation I had
there that made me think about doing
this lord of the rings video.
Anyway,
I really enjoyed that and I just like
meeting face to face people who watch
the show because you guys are so
freaking smart and you all have
different favorite videos,
which makes me really happy because I
like doing so many different things.
Um.
Anyway,
it was awesome to meet you.
Hopefully they do more of those again
soon.
The rest of you.
I'll see you next Wednesday.